OF OUR DISTINGUISHED GUESTS FROM
THE JUDICIARY.
WE'RE GONNA ASK THAT ALL MEMBERS.
IN THE CHAMBERS AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE TAKE THEIR
SEATS.
WE'RE GONNA BE STARTING
MOMENTARILY
TAKE YOUR SEATS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE WELCOME TO CALIFORNIA'S
THE ANNUAL STATE OF THE
JUDICIARY I'M LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR A LENNY KULA LAKIS.
I'M I HAVE BEEN ASKED BY THE
SENATE PRO TEM TO BEGIN THIS
MORNING WITH AN ECONOMICS MEN
AND A MOMENT OF SILENCE FOR THE
TRAGEDY I LAST WEEKEND IN NEW
ZEALAND.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
SILENCE
.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU LET'S GET
STARTED.
SENATORS GALGIANI ROTH RUBIO AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS QUIRK SILVA
MURDERED SU CHI AND HOLDEN
PLEASE GO TO THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBERS. TO ESCORT GOVERNOR NEW
SOME TO THE ROSTRUM.
PLEASE ESCORT THE GOVERNOR TO
THE ROSTRUM
.
I THINK I JOIN EVERYONE HERE IN
HI IN THANKING YOU AND
RECOGNIZING ARE THE HONOR OF
YOUR PRESENCE HERE TODAY
GOVERNOR THANK YOU.
SENATORS JACKSON GORGEOUS
MITCHELL ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MARK
STONE GONZALEZ AND CERVANTES
PLEASE GO TO THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBERS TO ESCORT THE CHIEF
JUSTICE TO THE ROSTRUM
.
PLEASE ESCORT THE CHIEF JUSTICE
TO THE ROSTRUM
[inaudible]
MADAM SENATOR I AM VERY GRATEFUL
AND HONORED TO BE HERE WITH ALL
OF YOU TODAY.
I'M ESPECIALLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADD MY VOICE TO
THE CHORUS OF THOSE WHO TODAY
WILL RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
A JUST FAIR EFFICIENT ACCESSIBLE
AND ABOVE ALL.
INDEPENDENT JUDICIARY TO A
STRONG AND HEALTHY DEMOCRACY.
WHEN I SERVED OVERSEAS
REPRESENTING OUR COUNTRY I OFTEN
SPOKE ABOUT AMERICAN DEMOCRACY
AND WHAT HAS ALLOWED IT TO WIN
DO YOUR FOR WELL OVER TWO
CENTURIES?
THE LONGEST AND STRONGEST
DEMOCRACY IN HISTORY.
AND I FOUND MYSELF REPEATING A
COMMON REFRAIN.
DEMOCRACY IS ALWAYS A WORK IN
PROGRESS. FOR OUR COUNTRY AND
FOR ANY COUNTRY.
AND IN DURING DEMOCRACY MUST
POSSESS THE ABILITY TO ADAPT AND
MODERNIZE TO BE NIMBLE AND
RESPONSIVE TO CHANGING TIMES
WHILE IT HEARING THE TIME TESTED
PRINCIPLES.
FINDING THE BALANCE REQUIRES
HARD WORK SOMETIMES MESSY
SOMETIMES CONFLICT BUILD BUT
ALWAYS IN THE IN TRASHED OF
BUILDING A BETTER STRONGER
SYSTEM FOR THE NEXT GENERATION
AND FUTURE GENERATIONS TO COME.
SO AGAIN IT IS A GREAT HONOR TO
BE HERE AND IT IS MY PRIVILEGE
TO WELCOME.
THE SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY THE
HONORABLE ANTHONY RENDON THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU IS A PRIVILEGE TO BE
HERE TODAY FOR THE CHIEF
JUSTICE'S ANNUAL ADDRESS ON THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA JUDICIARY.
JUST A FEW DAYS AGO ARE%
COURAGEOUS GOVERNOR STOOD
OUTSIDE OF THESE DOORS AND MADE
A MOMENTOUS ANNOUNCEMENT.
ABOUT JUSTICE IN CALIFORNIA.
GOVERNOR NEWSOME HAD THE
PORTRAIT OF ONE OF HIS
PREDECESSORS FOR A WARRANT OVER
HIS SHOULDER.
AS CHIEF JUSTICE OF THE US
SUPREME COURT FOR A WARRANT WAS
ALSO ONE OF THE STATE'S MOST
ILLUSTRIOUS MEMBERS OF THE
JUDICIARY.
IS A REMINDER THAT WHETHER WE
TAKE OUR BOLD STEPS TO THE
FUTURE.
AS THE EXECUTIVES JUSTICES OR
LEGISLATORS WE ARE PART OF THE
CONTINUUM HISTORY.
NOW IT IS MY HONOR TO INTRODUCE
ONE OF OUR CURRENT.
BOLD LEGISLATIVE LEADERS MY
FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE THE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM TONI ATKINS.
GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES WELCOME
TO OUR DISTINGUISHED GUEST STAR
FRIENDS AND FAMILY MEMBERS HERE.
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
WELCOME THE ELECTED OFFICIALS
PRESENT TODAY THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE LEGAL
COMMUNITY INCLUDING THE STATE
BAR AND THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
MR GVERNOR THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE HONOR OF YOUR PRESENCE
HERE TODAY.
TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS IS MORE THAN
TRADITION OR SYMBOLISM.
THAT EACH BRANCH OF STATE
GOVERNMENT COMES TOGETHER AS WE
ARE HERE TODAY AND YET REMAINS
DISTINCT AND SOVEREIGN IN ITS
OWN RIGHT.
IT IS THE FOUNDATION OF OUR
DEMOCRACY.
IT IS THE ESSENTIAL PRECAUTION
IN FAVOR OF LIBERTY AS MADISON
WROTE IN THE FEDERALIST.
FORTY SEVEN BECAUSE THE
ACCUMULATION OF ALL POWERS
LEGISLATIVE EXECUTIVE AND
JUDICIARY IN THE SAME HANDS.
IS THE VERY DEFINITION OF
TYRANNY DAY WE RENEW OUR
COMMITMENT TO THAT ESSENTIAL
PRECAUTION WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
TOGETHER AND YET PROBABLY
DISTINCT.
WITH THAT IS MY GREAT PLEASURE
TO INTRODUCE CALIFORNIA'S
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES
[inaudible]
MAIN CHEN [inaudible]
CAROL CORRIGAN [inaudible]
GOODWIN LIU.
MARIANO FLORENTINO QUAY ARE.
LEON --
KRUEGER.
AND JOSH WERE GROPING.
SHE IS THE FIRST ASIAN FILIPINO
AMERICAN THE SECOND WOMAN TO
SERVE AS THE STATE'S CHIEF
JUSTICE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THE
CHIEF JUSTICE OF THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT TINY CONTEL SECCO
WAY
.
THANK YOU I THANK YOU LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR COULD UNLOCK AS
PRESIDENT PRO TEM ATKINS AND
SPEAKER RENDON FOR THOSE
INTRODUCTIONS.
AND THANK YOU GOVERNOR FOR BEING
HERE YOU HONOR US WITH YOUR
PRESENCE.
I AM THANKFUL TO BE HERE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE SUPREME
COURT.
AND ALSO MEMBERS OF THE
JUDICIARY INCLUDING THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL BENCH BAR COALITION AND
OPEN COURTS COALITION I'M
GRATEFUL THAT SOME OF MY BELOVED
FAMILY MEMBERS ARE HERE MY
HUSBAND MARK.
MY IN LAWS BUREAU AND DOROTHY MY
SISTER IN LAW VICKI AND FRIENDS.
THE MOTTO OF THE SENATE.
IS TO GUARD THE LIBERTY OF THE
PEOPLE.
THIS MOTTO IS IN ACCORD WITH THE
CONSTITUTIONAL DEMOCRACY THAT
LINK IN ENVISIONED WITH THE
GOVERNMENT OF THE PEOPLE BY THE
PEOPLE AND FOR THE PEOPLE.
OUR CALIFORNIA THREE BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT STRIVE TO PUT THE
PEOPLE'S RIGHTS.
PROTECTIONS AND FREEDOMS FIRST.
EVEN WITHOUR DISTINCT ROLES AND
DIFFERENT POWERS AND THE
NECESSARY CHECKS AND BALANCES OF
GOOD GOVERNMENT WE ALL ARE
GUARDIANS OF THE PEOPLE'S
LIBERTY.
EACH GENERATION ENDEAVORS TO
CHANGE THE PRESENT FOR THE
FUTURE CASE IN POINT.
WE ARE APPROACHING THE ONE
HUNDREDTH ANNIVERSARY.
OF THE NINETEENTH AMENDMENT
GIVING WOMEN THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
GENERATIONS FOUGHT FOR THIS
RIGHT AND ITS IMPORT CANNOT BE
OVERSTATED BECAUSE THE RIGHT TO
VOTE.
IS THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
IS THE RIGHT TO PARTICIPATE AND
IT'S THE RIGHT TO BE HEARD.
ALL ARE NECESSARY ELEMENTS IF WE
ARE TO OUR BIRTHRIGHT TO JUSTICE.
MANY OF US ARE HERE TODAY
BECAUSE OF THE SACRIFICE AND
DETERMINATION OF THOSE PAST
GENERATIONS.
SO TODAY IN SPEAKING TO YOU
ABOUT THE STATE OF THE JUDICIARY
I START WITH THE FACT.
THAT ABOUT ONE THIRD OF OUR
JUSTICES AND JUDGES ARE
RELATIVELY NEW TO THEIR
POSITIONS.
THANKS TO GOVERNOR BROWN WHO
BREATHE NEW LIFE INTO THE
JUDICIARY WITH SIX HUNDRED PLUS
JUDICIAL APPOINTMENTS TWO
HUNDRED OF THOSE IN HIS FINAL
YEAR.
IN THE LAST YEAR THESE NEW
APPOINTEES SELF REPORT THAT 41%
ARE NON WHITE.
AND OVER HALF OF THESE
APPOINTMENTS ARE FEMALE.
THIS IS TO LET YOU KNOW THAT THE
JUDICIARY NOW IS MORE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE IN EVERY
WAY.
WE'VE ALSO MADE PROGRESS WITH
YOUR HELP.
BECAUSE WE ARE MORE FOCUSED ON
OUR GOALS AND OUR PLANS AND WE
HAVE WHAT WE CALL ACCESS THREE
D. VISION FOR ACCESS TO JUSTICE.
THE ACCESS TO JUSTICE BE THREE
DIMENSIONAL ONE OF COURSE THAT
IT BE PHYSICAL FOR YOUR DAY IN
COURT. TO TO BE REMOTE --
ONLINE SO YOU CAN ACCESS
INFORMATION AND TOOLS AND
KNOWLEDGE AND THREE THAT IT BE
EQUAL ACCESS.
SO PHYSICAL ACCESS IS OF COURSE
COURTROOMS IN COURTHOUSES WITH
YOUR HELP WE MAINTAIN OVER FIVE
HUNDRED COURTHOUSES IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE ARE CONSTRUCTING TEN NEW
SAFE AND SECURE COURTHOUSES IN
THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES WE SERVE.
REMOTE ACCESS MEANS ONLINE
ACCESS IT MEANS YOU MAY
CONDUCTOR LEGAL BUSINESS VIA AN
APP.
OR VIDEO FOR THOSE WHO CHOOSE TO
DO SO. TO YOUR FUNDING OF OUR
INNOVATIVE GRANT PROGRAM LOCAL
COURT SERVE AS INCUBATORS FOR
OVER FIFTY NEW PROJECTS THAT
INCLUDE THE NEW TECHNOLOGY.
SO THAT WE MAY EVENTUALLY TEST
THIS NEW TECHNOLOGY AND USE IT
STATE WIDE.
THIS NEW TECHNOLOGY INCLUDES
THINGS LIKE A MOBILE APP.
A MULTI LINGUAL SELF HELP
WEBSITE.
AVATAR GUIDES A VIDEO HEARINGS
AND VIDEO REMOTE INTERPRETERS.
THESE GRANTS ALLOW THE JUDICIARY
TO PROTOTYPE AND BETA TEST THESE
NEW PROGRAMS A NEW POLICIES IN
NEW PROJECTS.
SO THAT WE CAN REPLICATE THEM
STATEWIDE FOR OTHER COURTS.
BECAUSE IMPROVING ONLINE ACCESS
TO JUSTICE IT MAKES SENSE IN
CALIFORNIA MANY CALIFORNIANS
EXPECT THIS KIND OF SERVICE FROM
THEIR COURTS.
YET WE MUST ALWAYS REMEMBER AND
UNDERSTAND THAT TECHNOLOGY CAN
ONLY TAKE US SO FAR.
JUSTICE WILL ALWAYS REQUIRE A
HUMAN TOUCH WE WILL ALWAYS NEED
JUDGES AND COURT STAFF AND
LAWYERS TO LISTEN TO PEOPLE IN
CRISIS. TO GUIDE THEM AND TO
HELP.
AN ESTIMATED FOUR AND A HALF
MILLION PEOPLE COME TO COURT
EACH YEAR WITHOUT AN ATTORNEY
SEEKING JUSTICE THESE FOLKS NEED
HELP TO ACCESS OUR COURT SYSTEM
AND TO PRESS THEIR RIGHTS.
THAT'S WHY I'VE ADVOCATED FOR
WAY FINDERS OR WHAT WE CALL
COURT NAVIGATORS.
THIS IS EQUAL ACCESS TO JUSTICE
THE THIRD COMPONENT OF ACCESS
THREE D..
IN THE STATE AS DIVERSE AND
INCLUSIVE LIKE CALIFORNIA WE
WILL ALWAYS BE WORKING ON ACCESS
TO JUSTICE. FOR EXAMPLE A FEW
YEARS AGO WE DECIDED TO STUDY
THE NEED FOR LANGUAGE ACCESS IN
THE COURTS WE ISSUED A REPORT.
WE MADE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
RECENTLY WE IMPLEMENTED THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS THANKS TO THE
EXCEPTIONAL LEADERSHIP OF
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE TINO QUAY
ARE.
YOU KNOW WILL TELL YOU IT'S
BECAUSE OF MY OUTSTANDING TASK
FORCE COMMITTEE WHICH IS TRUE --
BUT THANKS TO THEIR EFFORT.
AND YOUR FUNDING WE NOW PROVIDE
INTERPRETERS IN CRITICAL CIVIL
CASES LIKE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
CHILD CUSTODY ELDER ABUSE ANY
FICTIONS WE'VE EXPANDED THE USE
OF MULTI LINGUAL SIGNAGE IN THE
COURTS AND WE ALSO NOW PROVIDE
INTERPRETERS AT SERVICE DESKS
[inaudible]
NOW.
BUT IS JUST AS QUICKLY.
TOLD US THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
JUST LAST WEEK WE HAVE MUCH MORE
WORK TO DO.
BUT WE ARE COMMITTED TO DOING
THAT WORK.
EVERY GENERATION IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR CREATING DEMOCRACY AND NEW.
A DEMOCRACY THAT IS RELEVANT AND
RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS OF THAT
GENERATION ONE THAT EXPANDS UPON.
AND COMPLETES THE PREVIOUS WORK
OF THE PRIOR GENERATION.
IN MY VIEW THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT THAT BEGAN IN THE
FIFTIES REMAINS UNFINISHED.
DALY WE HEAR IN THE NEWS ABOUT
ACTIONS LIKE HASH TAG BLACK
LIVES MATTER HASH TAG ME TO HASH
TAG TIME'S UP.
JUST TO NAME A FEW.
FREDERICK DOUGLASS SAID.
WHERE JUSTICE IS DENIED?
WHERE POVERTY IS ENFORCED
IGNORANCE PREVAILS WHERE ANY ONE
CLASS IS MADE TO FEEL THAT
SOCIETY IS AN ORGANIZED
CONSPIRACY? TO ALL PRESS ROB OR
DEGRADE THEM.
NEITHER PERSON NOR PROPERTY IS
SAFE.
WE IN THE JUDICIARY RECOGNIZE
THIS AND WE NEED TO WORK ON OUR
OWN CHALLENGES.
WE MUST ENSURE THAT INCOME
INEQUALITY DOESN'T TRANSLATE
INTO A TWO TIERED JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WE MUST ENSURE THAT FINES AND
FEES NO LONGER FALL ON THOSE
LEAST ABLE TO AFFORD THEM.
WE MUST ENSURE THAT MINOR
TRAFFIC OFFENSES DON'T TURN FOR
DRIVERS INTO POOR CRIMINALS.
WE MUST ENSURE THAT WE KEEP OUR
WORKPLACES SAFE AND FREE FROM
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT IN
THAT WE TREAT EACH OTHER.
AT THE PUBLIC WE SERVE WITH
RESPECT.
WE NEED OUR CHALLENGES IN THE
JUDICIARY BY CONVENING THE MOST
KNOWLEDGEABLE DELIBERATING THE
FACTS AND THE LAW AND THEN
PURSUING RECOMMENDATIONS TO ALL
THREE BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT
BECAUSE WE HAVE LEARNED.
AS GOVERNOR NEWSOME SAID IN HIS
STATE OF THE STATE.
THAT WE GO FAR WHEN WE GO
TOGETHER.
SO AN EXAMPLE OF THIS CONVENING
ISN'T WE CONVENED A WORK GROUP
TO STUDY THE PRACTICES AND
REFORM OF EXISTING PRE TRIAL
DETENTION.
AND WE ASK THIS TASK FORCE TO
COME BACK WITH NEXT STEPS TO
MAKE THIS PROCESS.
FAIRER AND SAFER WE THANK
GOVERNOR NEWSOME FOR HIS VISION
HIS RESOLVE AND HIS COMMITMENT
TO FAIRNESS AND SAFETY WITH HIS
PROPOSAL OF SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. TO THE COURTS TO
DEVELOP INTO EIGHT PRE TRIAL
DETENTION DECISION MAKING COURTS
EIGHT TO TEN COURTS AND ALL.
WE ARE GRATEFUL AND I'M THANKFUL
THAT I SEE ONE OF OUR PARTNERS
IN THIS EFFORT HERE TODAY THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA CHIEF
STEPHANIE JAMES [inaudible]
THE LEADER.
HER COUNTY IN PRE TRIAL
DETENTION REFORM.
AND WE THANK PROBATION FOR THEIR
PARTNERSHIP.
AND FOR HELPING US LEAD THE WAY.
WE THANK CHIEF JAMES AND SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP EFFORTS AND FOR
GENEROUSLY SHARING THEIR TIME
AND THEIR KNOWLEDGE WITH THOSE
WHO ARE WILLING AND OPEN TO
CHANGING THEIR PRACTICES.
ANOTHER METHOD OF SHOWING OUR
WAY WITH OF CONVENING IS OUR
WORK GROUP ON THE PREVENTION AND
DISCRIMINATION OF HARASSMENT AND
ABUSE.
WE HAVE A WORK GROUP THAT WILL
COME BACK TO US IN THE SUMMER.
WITH RECOMMENDATIONS WE HOPE
JUSTICE HILL TO AND JUDGE BORE
YURI TO MAKE OUR WORKPLACE SAFER.
RESPECTFUL AND BETTER FOR ALL.
OUR ADMINISTRATIVE DIRECTOR
MARTIN WHO SHE NOW HAS ALREADY
ACTED IN THIS REGARD HE HAS MADE
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS TRAINING
MANDATORY FOR ALL JUDICIAL
COUNCIL EMPLOYEES BECAUSE HE
RECOGNIZES THE SCIENCE AS TO WHY.
THAT THE FORMATION OF
UNCONSCIOUS STEREO TYPES CAN
AFFECT ATTITUDES ACTIONS AND
BELIEVES IT ALL ENCOUNTERS WHERE
WE MEET SOMEONE DIFFERENT FROM
OURSELVES.
I'VE ASKED MARTIN TO REVIEW OUR
STATE Y. JUDICIAL EDUCATIONAL
CURRICULUM. TO ENSURE THAT THIS
KIND OF TRAINING IS AVAILABLE
FOR JURISTS BECAUSE I PLAN ON
TAKING THE FIRST CLASS.
IN CLOSING I WANT TO PAY TRIBUTE
TO WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH.
BY NOTING THAT ONE HUNDRED YEARS
AFTER GIVING US THE RIGHT TO
VOTE.
WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA HAVE TRULY
MADE THEIR MARK.
CURRENTLY OUR PRESIDENT FIRST
FEMALE TO LEAD THIS AUGUST BODY.
WE HAVE THIRTY SIX FEMALE
LEGISLATORS.
DOWN FOR MORE MAJORITY BUT WE
STILL HAVE THREE CURRENT FEMALE
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES.
IN OUR LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR OUR
CONTROLLER ARE TREASURER OR ALL
FEMALE.
THE LAST THREE FEMALE CHIEFS OF
STAFF TO THE GOVERNOR FEMALE.
THE CURRENT CHIEF OF STAFF TO
THE GOVERNOR IS EMAIL.
IN OUR FIRST PARTNER IS A
FILMMAKER WRITER PRODUCER
DIRECTOR AND WORKING MOM.
I OFTEN MENTION THAT HAMILTON
QUOTE THAT LAWS ARE A DEAD
LETTER WITHOUT THE COURTS BUT
THIS TIME I'M GOING TO END WITH.
HAMILTON AN AMERICAN MUSICAL.
NO SINGING.
HAMILTON'S SISTER IN LAW
ANGELICA SCHUYLER SAYS THAT SHE
APPRECIATES THAT THE DECLARATION
OF INDEPENDENCE HOLD THESE
TRUTHS TO BE SELF EVIDENT.
THAT ALL MEN ARE CREATED EQUAL
BUT WHEN SHE MEETS THOMAS
JEFFERSON SHE'S GOING TO COMPEL
HIM TO PUT WOMEN IN THE SEQUEL.
I SUBMIT TO YOU THAT THE
NINETEENTH AMENDMENT PUT US IN
THE SEQUEL.
AND NOW WE'RE READY FOR THE
THIRD INSTALLMENT.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING
[inaudible]
CHIEF JUST TOO ONEROUS WITH YOUR
PRESENCE HERE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER.
ON BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUE
SPEAKER RENDON AND I WE WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE ADDRESS TODAY
THANK YOU FOR BEING OUR GUEST
TODAY AGAIN.
GOVERNOR THANK YOU TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE SENATE AND THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR THANK YOU.
AND TO OUR INCREDIBLE CONTROLLER
BETTY THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH
US TODAY.
AND I UNDERSTAND THERE'S A
RECEPTION --
AT FOUR THIRTY AT THE LIBRARY IN
COURTS BUILDING ACROSS THE
STREET AND I'M ASSUMING WE'RE
ALL INVITED SINCE I JUST
ANNOUNCED IT TO A TO EVERYONE
HERE -- BUT
TO THE MEMBERS OF THE JUDICIARY
AND OUR OUR LEGAL COMMUNITY I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BEING OUR
GUEST TODAY HAVE A WONDERFUL DAY